thank you
[Music]
welcome to a very Mexican episode of
careful
not only to have Jesus
she makes Chinese kids
of course dude I love it I appreciate
that I'm glad you feel at home a lot
when I went to Mexico I realized
I didn't leave home really yeah Mexico
is nice when you grow up in L.A but like
not the white part of La you're
basically in Mexico
yeah those are facts yeah he just said
was facts yes you say I love Mexico I
said I was gonna say yeah I love East LA
too because you're technically that's
how it feels like what's all of L.A
though
do the Mexicans run it really Puerto
Rico uh Pico Rivera
dude they're sneaking into Cerritos too
but isn't the Mexican their way to
Cerritos is it the mayor Mexican
or he was oh of La yeah is he still a
man I think that fool was a [__]
banger
he's my gangster guy
like he just had this look to him like
no no I got that part but slick back
hair like he looked like he would just
wear like hair now yeah it kind of has
like this dance that you can't really
[__] with him his feet
he's got that look like he's ready to
tell you like hey were you from yeah
yeah he has that
just traveling and being with the baby
and just coming home and getting all
like emotional like let's just grow it I
should just stay home I work too much
that's what I show her and then when I
hit the [__] bathroom like [__] that
dude
hit that road baby will you leave the
house I just all right one more time
I'll see you guys later hit the [__] the
car starts on yeah
you're on the road a lot huh yeah dude a
lot dude a lot of [__] JK news fans
are here
do a lot you guys have a lot of little
fans you know they show up if you
were like talking about you you
um please tag JK news anytime you go to
any of his shows yes yes please the
Instagram okay there you go dude I'm
just like where all these Asians come
from
a lot of Mexican uh uh fans too hell
yeah we got half a half we do I would
say we got like 40 Mexican 40 Asians
wait didn't you just eat one of those
I could do whatever I want I ain't on a
[__] diet 20 other and what I love is
that you guys talk them to like not give
a [__] about anything I like that really
how other fans are very like ah I get
offended you your fans oh yeah I'm not
gonna be good yeah they're awesome they
know what's up dude hey you know they're
like they just taught them well because
they've been watching us since 16.
and then and then they're like You
Raised Me they're like I was watching
you since seven and I'm like I infected
you harder than your parents ever could
call me daddy [__] insect is a good
word I like that but the way you said it
got me a full chub right now I said that
very soon I saw you here I'm sure they
feel like they know you you raised me
you gave me hope about life and I'm like
you don't even know the real me but I
[__] got in your brain [__]
wow that's very that's very aggressive
but yeah our audience is a lot of
Mexicans like perfectly half and half
yeah it is it is so I've been trying
wow I like what you did there dude that
was great
fifth Red Bull he starts getting off
[__] spirituals
but yeah they're just mostly traveling
and taking care of the baby what's new
with the baby the new with the wall uh
uh everything is growing even his penis
which I'm concerned I'm like what's
going on that is not mice where's this
guy he's not from my team I'll tell you
that much but he's growing
he's he's seven months he's doing the he
finally flipped all the way which is a
big deal I know you look at your face
was just ready to go and [__] dance
or something
I didn't have time to worry about it
right now yeah he's ready to do a flip
it's a baby in his mind he's just doing
whatever you do what does that mean
um that means he it's a big deal when
they flip because he has control of his
body now he's starting to like flip from
one side to the other second before he's
like a turtle he doesn't really know how
to oh I didn't know there's a thing and
then when he shut the [__] up
[__] I have a present parent no yeah
this is getting wild that's the first
crawl is the thing I didn't know a flip
was a thing even when they lift up their
head that's a thing are you [__]
kidding me how many times baby you
[__] up with the Latino take that
money
he [__] up and went way with the
Latina well you're feisty you're feisty
you will speak up your mind
wait you speak up your mind the way
you're making me nervous right now
that's what I mean good get your heart
pumping up look at me I'm already
nervous I'm like sweating a little bit I
need to fight somebody I keep them young
that's how young he looks looks great I
know if you're married an Asian you
won't hear the fire she just divorces
you yeah they they bottle it down they
push it down they bottle it down and
then they go you know why why you should
be mad and I'm like oh man here we go
again with you really think I'm smarter
than you think I am wow but hers just
like breaks like his favorite thing and
then girl I'm over it
yeah whatever it is like whatever he
loves and he works on she's like yeah it
just just gets misplaced have you ever
have you ever broken any never broken
anything because his heart a fake one
like bug can fake oh really
yeah but flipping keep them on track
what are you talking about [__] stay
on track he's more Mexican than me I
don't mind breaking a diet though asian
bar sounds more Mexican than Geo yeah
yeah you got more Mexican energy how old
is your son now for sure seven months
but yeah flipping was a big deal dude
he's flipping and he has his tongue out
all the time
yeah
do you think he looks like you no
definitely does not look at me he looks
like his mama look and she rubs in my
face every [__] time and I'm just
like what I don't wanna take which is
great because I'm not the best looking
guy you don't take a test just to make
sure you don't think take a test
yeah he does certain things that I know
it's it's me for sure like my hair is
like that dumb look it's all me dude I'm
like that's me
when I want you to move it I'm taking
care of we're both like
she took a picture and I'm like oh yeah
okay it's about right that's that's me
you want more now are you like oh I
would want more but she's she's like no
wait I think it's just it's fresh right
now you know yeah you were here
marinated I'm gonna do a sneak attack I
don't know what I mean
if he's still healing yes thank you for
um sure let's talk about her [__]
didn't I hear you know how long does it
take to heal well I just think it's
oh yeah
that's what I think what do you think
that is the boys club
I think it's like three months how bad
you beat it up real good it takes a
while it takes it takes a long time
actually no I just think it's uh or
figuring out the sleeping arrangements
and working and we're just both because
she's still working yeah you know what I
mean yeah you know what I mean and that
sex part this is
both the other working we still we still
watch the candle we're working the
hardest to like send emails oh [__] yeah
you're trying to edit a video or like
[__] and then I just feel like how
stupid my job is like I'm so so stupid
I'm making it real I'm editing it I'm so
stupid in the real while I'm taking care
of a baby I'm like my dad was like doing
real hardcore labor like it's a real man
[__] and I'm over here holding you and
doing the hammer yeah through you you're
doing a tick tock yeah exactly I'm over
here doing the stupid [__] got a wig
on trying to act like
a trump supporter
this is a dude
that's my life I'm a clown
but yeah so he's just growing you know
and um I'm excited to hear him talk and
like hear what he is it's the best part
that's what I'm excited for the first
word is gonna be pendejo
so here's oh here's there I'm glad you
guys are here right and I'm going to get
your perspective because here's the
thing here's the beef at the house right
I gotta watch what I say with the kid
but I'm like he's seven months yeah kid
ain't talking no so I can say whatever
the [__] I want new parent [__] but he's
gonna absorb your energy and the things
you're saying and I'm like Izzy though
because I can say I feel like I can say
whatever the [__] I want that's what
that's what my wife says me about the
cats but I know yeah right right
exactly wow are you serious you can't
customize your cat she's just like they
understand your energy and then what's
gonna happen they don't understand
English they do understand you I know
they understand and but no matter what
even if I didn't cuss and I still gave
them energy it's the same [__] so what
if I cuss you know right that's true
because it's just all that is it's just
an emotion and something you want to get
out it's a form of expression that's
what I'm saying whether you actually say
the words they still feel it so right
now our kid taika like we've been
hearing them get closer is closer and
closer to the same bad word oh it's so
funny but before it looks close start
off with they'll say like record Decker
and then it started going to like mother
daughter mother daughter and then
something and then one time
it was really close and then we heard
him actually say [__] so we have
to replace him like don't say that say
mother lover and there's another mother
love him I have to say mother love a lot
which is really funny but he still gets
to express it still cuss around him I
mean it's just the way life is gonna be
for him yeah but he knows figure
[Laughter]
we keep it real and we're like dude this
is appropriate this is inappropriate I
mean it is what it is
um and then when he hears those guys
he'll be like oh oh and then he and then
I'm like would you hear dude and he'll
be like you said [__] and I'm like oh
that sounds funny
he'll repeat it and then now you'll
string them all together like if he's
playing a game record Decker mother
daughter mother love her face this is
the funniest way to cuss though you know
what I mean probably the best way yeah
probably the best way it's like Kidz Bop
that's what it is it's kids Bob cussing
and I like that I'm gonna use that
strategy was it lover do you feel like
you're gonna teach your son Spanish or
English first
question dude my mom wants to know the
answer too he's like what are you gonna
do are you gonna teach you how am I
gonna communicate you're late she
doesn't speak Spanish oh my lady that's
very Latino is your lady uh
is he your baby mama or your wife
well how did you guys how did you guys
decide whether to teach him martial arts
or not defend himself
I don't know how to defend myself I was
just choosing between Asian and Mexican
I don't think you have a choice I think
it's just whatever is the most spoken in
the home does he speak it I want to
speak Spanish well do you speak Spanish
with the lady do you both speak Spanish
we don't then he's not he's very
embarrassed he's like second generation
so she's very Americanized like her
Spanish is like she's gonna be your
baby's gonna be speaking in English for
sure but I'm gonna try to force a little
bit of Spanish but it's weird because I
don't really know Spanish like that well
I know like streets man if you speak to
your lady in Spanish like I look like I
know like taquero Spanish
performance
I don't like Street language that's the
language of the land here
this is
I mean do you guys uh are you gonna
answer away but like if only he's in
Spain maybe you're a kid you're teaching
them some uh well my mom helped us raise
uh so yeah when when her mom was staying
with us she only speaks Spanish he knew
the most Spanish and then when she left
that it's mainly English
and it's just whatever I don't think you
have a choice it's whatever is happening
is what they're gonna pick up I mean I
was like I'll take care of the Spanish
you take care of the English I mean the
Chinese
the Chinese and this guy kept talking to
him in Spanish he's [__] up by Spanish
because it's a little bit easier and I'm
like bro what are you doing he's looking
up words
legit Spanish but I'm like dude do you
know Chinese stick to that I can't speak
to him in Chinese are you like first
generation yeah oh is your Spanish
pretty good no it's okay you're supposed
better than mine oh really describing
with this guy for almost 20 years it's
gone really I don't practice with
anybody you should teach them yeah you
should do a little bit he does a little
bit he knows I would like to learn some
GJ Chong I would love to learn some
cheaters I'll teach right now I'll teach
yourself my son knows give me something
beads you know what that means shut up
right
[Laughter]
because I'm mimicking with your whole
like pingle
I have to work at a Korean restaurant
like it's a dishwasher so I know
I don't know what the [__] that but it
was just like no about what's coming out
I hit on one of the Wagers and they got
all like [__] uh what do you mean I
think I don't think uh we're ready to
bridge yeah they're gonna rain a mix
with uh Latinos yet you know what I mean
I mean Koreans they don't want to mix
with other Asians is that what it is
yeah they're like trying to be the
master race Master race it's working
dude that's top share hot right now are
they popping they're popping around
it's always funny coming from a Japanese
voice they're trying to be the master
race yeah well I heard about their
Japanese dude with the Japanese
companies they did a good job almost
being the Master
Drivers yeah yeah uh Japanese like to me
I feel like they're like like super like
meat like everything is supposed to be
neat like this is a reef there's these
here yeah like all their underwears
[Laughter]
take it easy [__] Japanese lady
Perfection what's the matter what's the
Mexican version of this
for the Mexican version of this look at
Mexican now hey give me the goddamn
thing again
that's Mexican [__] dude but I feel a
lot of like Asian restaurants and
Japanese is the only one
who's talking about though can I show up
and I just feel like I don't want to
ruin anything you just kind of leave
everything neat and you just kind of you
kind of [__] want to talk like this
it's so clean they're very orderly yeah
like we went to that Shabu Restaurant in
Vegas and they open at five right we're
outside at 4 50 because we always go to
sleep early because our kid has seizures
we have to get to bed soon we get to the
front of the restaurant the [__] lady
she's already ready to Surf like this
oh and I can sear it through the glass
right no more setting up or anything
she's ready to go this is with a smile
yes right and it's 450 I look at it I'm
like okay and then I go like can I come
inside
and then I was like okay I'll get it I'm
like I know she's Japanese I get it
we wait until 4 59. no and then I went
to go hold the door handle and she's
like
and I was like God damn damn and it was
literally at five I see her walk over to
the front of the door and unlock it so
can you can you can you see the Japanese
Ambassador please that's kind of like
Japanese [__] like that defies logic to
where it's not even smart yeah they they
follow rules over logic over Common
Sense yeah 450 bro [__] was done setting
up but yeah
not everyone's like that
Beefcake but I would say like all right
you know how like there's like New
Yorkers right and then there's like I
don't know like uh like Hawaii in Hawaii
it's like you're on island time right
we're still Americans but just hella
different culture like that's like
police must hate Hawaiians no they love
Hawaii they do but like uh Tokyo's
Filipinos they probably hate Filipinos
what's the beef with Filipinos well
Hawaiians are loose you know they could
be laid they could be early whatever and
the Japanese is like perfect I would
just like uh culture Clash I think
anything that has to be like in an
island they're laid back as far yeah
islands they're just laid back yeah the
culture is way more laid back even
Latinos are like by the island they're
just laid back as [__] they're chilling
but Japanese air is a whole other level
of like just organization huh very
organized I think yeah I agree what's
the messiest Asian
Vietnam was actually pretty clean when I
went there they didn't have that much
trash all over the place right now
whenever it's communion whatever's
convenient I don't know what it is it's
a Vietnamese Aloha right here that's
what taika's gonna have that's what the
privilege you gave him yeah yeah you
know what I mean he gets to be Asian
when it works
are Chinese uh clean
the pens are clean practical
so I don't think if I don't know if
anything is measured on the cleanliness
level definitely not it's just like it
feels very like but don't a lot of
Chinese people
litter yeah because it's practical don't
they take [__] on the streets because
it's practical practical no no Chinese
is like this right like if they're in
their car right they're like oh [__] I
got trashed man what the hell and like
see my car clean oh outside or say oh
man I got the pee dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'm like buddy every every or orifice
yeah oh my nose so clean my nose clean I
see that in Hong Kong very practical
very practical yeah
he took care of the problem and made him
he had a problem yeah
it's like a clean or not technically it
is like what's that thing in Shanghai
the dudes always fold their shirt up
because it's hot yeah they barely show
up yeah they just like chill like this
everywhere
I've seen the squad the Asian Squad I've
seen that a lot like when I first work
at UH Asian restaurants they're just
[__] in the in the alley smoking we
got flexible Achilles man just like
start doing and having a full
conversation like they're not doing this
yeah oh yeah my kids they don't go to
school [__] I'm like what the [__] you
oh my God you're gonna suck my dick
what's going on
it's [__] bombing and [__] that was
happening ladies too ladies too which is
like
it's hard to like not look
kind of like
just poking out what the [__] going on
there take that thing back in what the
[__] is happening are we not all seeing
this anyways but you know what I mean
but the squat legit yeah yeah is that
like a test who can do this test yeah
you know like it's the default Asian
sitting position well it's also like a
default like taking a [__] position
right it's the correct way you guys are
just ready to take a [__] whenever at
any time right at any time just like you
know what whenever he's got one in the
chamber yeah
thank you